yeah welcome to this video playing the
same case all over again against our
code here Grandmaster um grandmaster g
Chuck yeah I'm from Sweden originally um
what is it what I played I played h3
lining up against her he sometimes he
exactly i just wanted to mention that he
pleased places c6 d 5 which is not bad
at all it's one of the better off grid
lines and the kings in the NBC 6 and t6
first and then a transpose all the way
back here yeah can i play in this G
fourth style let's let's try that aha
now that's a very very direct way to to
play interesting
hmm
interesting should I just develop or is
it turn okay let's type it should be 3
i'm not sure door here b5 it's a cool
way to play he just wants to open up the
queenside as soon as possible of course
this is now a position where wow I
thought this was simply not playable
losing a look otherwise this is of
course a good idea but it gives us a
look here
yeah it's a bit bit unusual dispute
capture but if it wins a look I do it
yeah unless I'm overlooking something
here I probably just played this too
quickly don't even um see a way to to
just sacrifice an exchange or something
it's a it's really a whole look yeah I
can play knight c6 but if you rather
give away the rookie Allen when the
night I don't I don't see any way to to
get compensation mm or is there some way
okay the question is how to continue now
should I should I um casal law covering
that but it's castling right into the
open files I'm not sure that I want to
do that okay night d five maybe and to
quincy seven
hmm
young not sure at all
you're where to where to put my king
here
yeah come on this is I mean the question
is not if it is a winning I mean this is
of course winning for white but it's a
matter of blitz tricks what kind of
attenuation gives allows the least ideas
for counter play oh this is this is
actually nice how does he not exchange
the Queen this is the only way I take a
seven can go here but Rupert e6 looks
nice queen s no squares so long castles
was the right decision yeah just just a
piece for nothing okay this should be
too there should be towards
okay so let's just continue him I'm not
quite sure why he's playing on really
chances for 44 miracle are really very
slimming I mean chances for miracle are
always slow but in this case it's very
very slow
black resigned yeah he just he just
blended this I mean it so but it's a
fairly it's a fairly typical blunder in
a way because you all you never really
expect the bishop to take you always
think okay the bishop is the mobile you
look piece compared to the night and you
take with the night and it's not even a
bad move in this position I mean I mean
night x do you find this it's just a
night XD five is it's not not completely
ridiculous I mean you can take here but
it's a move to that you can can consider
but this is just just good the computer
however power points out 27 which I
didn't really see and ok of course I can
do that you can do that of course we
both didn't see that if i take now he
can go here with the idea to play we
should be seven hmm
yeah this was the way to go so it didn't
blunder look interesting hmm Gary both
uhh both didn't see that he invested
quite some time yet but we both thought
while is winning the thing is after
Queen g.711 important thing is that dumb
I don't need to actually take the rook
of course I can also play move like that
here which is probably not so bad of
course it's not like winning as thought
but it's still quite interesting yeah
but it didn't happen he just gave me
this piece alright thanks for watching